All right, so now that we have created our project
using the vehicle game template,
first thing we're going to do is we're going to locate
our game mode and set a timer up in there.
Now, the reason we want to use the game mode is this
is one just the best place for our code to exist.
The reason for that is that we can actually load
different levels with different game modes,
or I should say the same level with
different game modes to interact different types
of gameplay events.
So putting our code inside our game mode makes sense,
not necessarily because of the size of this project,
but just because it's good practice
for whenever you're working on larger projects.
So next thing,
let's go ahead and pop over here to the editor.
All right, so inside the editor,
I'm going to hit control space on my keyboard here,
control space, and my control is not working.
So we'll just come here to the content drawer.
And what we're going to be looking for here
is under our vehicle template, our blueprints,
and we want our vehicle advanced game modes.
Let's go ahead and double click on that to open it up.
Now, if we do open this up,
notice there's no blueprint editor.
That's not a problem.
In this particular case,
we're going to open up our full blueprint
and that will give us our blueprint editor.
Now, as we showed in the slide,
what we're going to do is we need to make a timer.
So first things first,
let's look for our event begin,
and we want this event begin play.
So when we first press play, stay spawn,
and we want to do something, and what are we going to do?
Well, we are going to set timer.
We want this set timer by event.
There we go, there's our event.
And we're going to connect these two like so.
And for our time on our timer,
we're going to go one second
and we're going to enable looping.
So what's going to happen is when we start,
we are going to set this timer by event.
And then every second it's going to recreate this event.
So we're going to basically create this one second
that's going to count down and then reset
and then count down and reset.
And we also need to add an event for this.
So what we're going to do
is we're going to look for a custom.
We're going to click on this event, add custom event.
And what we're going to be calling this is count down.
We go count down timer.
Now we're going to use this event here in a little bit
to actually make a little bit of code
that will count from whatever number we have down to zero.
And in order for that to function and send off the event,
we do need to do one thing first,
and that's going to connect this output delegate
to our event right here.
And we're going to see this is going
to start this timer off
and then we're going to do our countdown.
And when it reaches zero, we're going to fire this back
and it's going to keep going kind of in this loop.
Now, next thing that we need to do
is we need to give some variables
so that we can actually interact with this timer
so that we have some time.
So we're going to create a new variable
called time remaining.
We're going to set it to an integer
and we're going to give it a default value of 10.
So let's pop over to the editor and do that now.
So variables here, add another variable, time remaining,
and we're going to set it to a integer.
And then we're going to give it a default value.
But before we do that, we do need to compile it
and there's our default value, so 10.
So again, come over to your variables,
press the add variable.
We'll give it a name, time remaining in this case.
Press the compile button and then give it
a default value of 10.
And the final thing we're going to be doing now
is we're going to be making this a little bit of code here.
So basically, when our countdown event gets to zero,
we're going to fire something off of this condition.
And again, this is small, but everything
that has ever been built on has started off
as something very small and then worked and worked on,
worked on into something much, much larger.
Let's go ahead and build this small piece
so we can build something bigger later.
Now I'm going to expand my Blueprint editor like so.
And then I'm going to grab this time remaining
and I'm just going to drag and drop that right here.
And from the menu, I'm going to get
the value of time remaining because I
want to get that current value.
Now what I want to do next is
I want to take this time remaining
and I want to subtract from it.
So if I left click and drag off
of our execution of our countdown timer
and I go minus minus, I have this math float
and I have a, I'm sorry, not float,
I want integer and I want the decrement.
So basically a decrement will take one off
of whatever number is supplied in here.
So what I can do is then drag this right into here.
So as this goes through,
we're going to take our time remaining.
It's going to decrement, so subtract one from it
and then it's going to come through
and it'll be nine and then eight and seven
and six and five and four and three and two, one
all the way till zero.
So what happens when we get to zero?
Well, what we're going to do is
we're going to pull off of this.
We're going to look for a branch
and there we go, flow control branch.
There's our branch statement.
And again, remember a branch is Unreal's
if then statement or true and false.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to take this result
and we are going to look for the less than,
so utility operator less than,
and I got that just by putting the less than
keyboard symbol into the search and clicked on it.
Boom, right there.
So when that reaches,
or I should say when it reaches zero,
when this value right here is less than zero,
we want to do something.
And what we want to do,
well, we are going to set that up here in the next video.